hard to believe there's a partial ban on
plastic bags in Ethiopia it's just not
working instead with little recycling to
talk of there are huge illegal plastic
waste lands Ethiopia's population is
growing fast but so too is its plastic
consumption and almost half of the
plastic used here is discarded
improperly it's getting into the food
chain the site you're about to see is
shockingly familiar in parts of rural
Ethiopia the young calf is getting local
anaesthetic the animal will stay awake
whilst they cut open its rumen and see
what's causing a blockage in the stomach
this one is a foreign body that is
plastic that looks like a plastic bags
plastic plastic oh that is quite a big
bit of plastic as well I couldn't
explain it is very bad for the forest as
you know this reduces the movement of
the Roman so anything cannot go to the
next compartment so it will accumulate
inside the Roman so it is very difficult
for Danny man and there's even more to
come their stomachs gone down so much
already this is a big problem for us we
should combat this problem since we
don't have a good management of waste is
proven at disposal every everybody is
dumping these plastic bags to the
everywhere so the animal will eat in
amongst all of this is someone's plastic
hairband there's plastic bags this huge
tangled web of trust plastic which is
some of it which has solidified it's
been in there all this in a one-year-old
cough the vets are even surprised and I
think it's indicative
of just how bad the problem is becoming
and the sheer scale of it within an hour
the CAF is looking a little bit stunned
but pretty much back to normal but the
vets fully expect to see him again
do you think the chances are that Hubert
Levesque and it's not just the animals
in danger
scientists believe microplastics are
being disseminated through the soil and
then into the water table if there's a
problem here at one of the sources of
the River Nile what are the implications
for the 300 million people reliant on
Africa's longest waterway for their
survival
Alex corset Sky News Ethiopia